-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
MyFamilyIsWeird stories
from you guys.
This first one is
from @Kimjohnston.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
This one's from @lea22089.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
That is weird.
-Yeah.
This one's from @Mariabarnes96.
She said...
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Not sexy.
-This one's from
@garrettsatfield.
I like that name.
-Garrett Satfield?
-Garrett Satfield.
Sounds like somebody
I'd be friends with.
-Yeah.
-I went out to dinner
the other night
with Garrett Satfield.
-How is Garrett?
-He's fantastic as always.
He's just a positive dude,
always nice.
-That's good.
-Happy -- he's married.
-Wife is lovely.
-Wife is great, too.
-Linda is lovely.
-Yeah.
We're having the Satfields
over for dinner...
-Are you really?
-...again
'cause I had so much fun
last night.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I'm going to do it every night
of the week.
-Oh, my gosh.
He's so fun.
You know how much fun he is?
-Who? You talking about GS?
-Yeah, GS.
[ Laughter ]
Gar-Man.
The garster.
Yeah, he's fantastic.
-Yeah, I just love
Garrett Satfield.
-Really?
How much do you love him?
-Well, I mean, I love my wife
and my kids.
-Right.
-But above all, Gary Statfield.
[ Laughter ]
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Grandpa!
Grandpa, we're at yellow
right now.
-Take the blanket with you.
-"I'm about to go yellow."
-Okay.
Is that right?
Brown light.
-Brown light, that's...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Danimichelle.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Yay, dad.
Get your money's worth.
-Now we learn how to drive
to the hospital.
Here we go.
This one's from @etess97.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-What?
-How would you know?
-I mean, they're not even
my grandparents,
and I want to unsee that.
-Oh, green light!
-The last one's from @crusty316.
He says...
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.